is this for me or is this for for c-span
okay I'm really sorry I'm late
broke down in Fort Wayne so where a lot
of cops on the way in but they didn't
stop me
so I deeply apologize and thank you so
much for sitting around for an hour
talking among yourselves about the
clinton scandal scandal probably I
passed a sign in Indiana saying fed up
with the scandal eat hamburger I'm of
the school that Clinton if ever there
was a fake populist it was Clinton he
hasn't even aspired practically to fake
populism but here he is in a way being
saved at the moment by a genuine
populism of people saying to the elites
and saying sex is private and who cares
I think it's a glorious moment in
American history myself if only to see
george will's face night after night the
CIA was the topic of the book that
Jeffrey and I decided to write
not long after Gary Webb got eviscerated
by the press after his disclosures in
1996 almost exactly two years ago August
1996 about the Contras and drug
smuggling have you had Gary here by the
way of people you have had Gary yes so I
won't go deeply into what he said for
those who weren't here I'm sure you're
familiar with this central charge and
what interested Jeffrey and me
originally was the the way when you step
out of line I thought the line of
mainstream discourse for want of a
better word in the American press
mainstream if you cross a certain line
you get done
we've actually seen a couple of cases
this summer in the form of my Galica who
wrote an incredible series of pieces in
the Cincinnati Enquirer about Chiquita
banana previously known as United Fruit
Company one of the best series actually
on a multinational corporation that ever
appeared in mainstream American
journalism or even on the left it was a
brilliant brilliant portrait for which
assiduous ness and tenacity he was
immediately fired and run out of the
profession fired under the accusation
that he'd got telephone conversation
Swiss the answer is he says he got him
from the source but so what here's one
of the distressing features of it was
the speed with which his colleagues
turned on him not a very nice profession
my one because in Gary Webb's case his
colleagues turned on him including his
own editor and his own colleagues at the
San Jose Mercury News you're gonna go in
you like solidarity and your business
don't be a journalist at least in the
mainstream and then of course we saw
this some of the case of April Oliver
and Jack Smith who did a piece for CNN
on the Tailwind use of sarin in Laos for
which documentary actually they did an
hour and it was cut to 18 minutes and
then they were accused of missing things
out they were of course fired and kicked
out so you've had all these cautionary
tales and that's what interested Jeffrey
and me cautionary tales where there are
certain areas you can't approach in
American journalism without getting into
deep trouble one is assassination so you
start saying the CIA actually abused
assassination is a method of national
policy for many years you get into
trouble you get into trouble if you
start kicking too deeply into the drugs
business and of course you get into
trouble if you start saying that major
American corporations subsist on
thievery and exploitation on in
lawful international scale and appear to
have conversations to prove it just used
to say when I started in journalism
comment is free and facts are expensive
but as Geoffrey and I sort of went
through how Gary was done we found
ourselves really beginning and the
parable of journalism and mainstream
journalism and what can be said and what
can't be said we found ourselves getting
more and more into the history of the
CIA and it crossed our minds that it was
about due for another introduction to
the agency some of the elder people
among you like myself were probably
introduced to the agency in 68 with the
disclosures in ramparts magazine now
marching under the rather limp guise of
Mother Jones that the CIA had had deep
sponsorship of the National Student
Association that was one of the first
big disclosures that had been courageous
cells had written earlier about the CIA
but that was wet when it wind really
went public that really launched a whole
decade and a bit of public disclosures
about the agency and the learning of
what the agency had been up to
if there's one a mission that I think
damaged Gary Webb it is that he didn't
really cite and of course when you're
doing that kind of end of journalism you
know you want to really say that your
paper always wants to say they invented
the bicycle you don't want to say that
there were previous inventors of the
bicycle and people even learned to ride
bicycles and you wanted you know it's
our bicycle we made it here it is Webb
didn't really invoke which he could have
done the fact that's been an enormous
amount of work I had being a brilliant
investigative work about the
relationship between the agency and
drugs and drug trafficking back in the
70s by the early seventies
Allen Ginsberg was in Yale one time the
late Allen Ginsberg the poet it was
chatting with a young student called Al
McCoy and said you know you who was
studying Southeast Asian languages and
said you were to really get in to the
relationship between the agency and
drugs in Southeast Asia during the
Vietnam War
McCoy went away and wrote one of the
most brilliant books on this subject
ever written and certainly the most
courageous or one of the most courageous
which was the politics of heroin in
Southeast Asia fantastic book which was
thoroughly trashed at the time the
agency tried to suppress its publication
at Morrow books failed and the book was
really read in a second edition in 1991
and I strongly commended we do an
extensive a kind of it not work there
was John Marx's book again based on
while this time based on Freedom of
Information Act documents not very many
of them about research for The
Manchurian Candidate about the CIA's
effort at mind-control its sponsorship
of enormous a number of experiments to
do with LSD hallucinogens
and other potions and pharmacological
mixtures many of them of a lethal nature
and of course there were the Senate
investigation chaired by the Senator
Frank church of Idaho and a house
investigation run by Otis Pike by the
end of the 70s therefore there was a
pretty full account a lot of
documentation about the cooze that the
agency had sponsored the some account of
the assassinations that had tied to
perpetrate notably of course Fidel
Castro but also Lumumba its complicity
in the murder of Lumumba and other
attempts the 80s were far more fallow
and really although there were massive
inquiries in the late 80s into the
relationship between the agency and drug
running particularly Senator Kerry's
investigation
and through the 90s there hasn't been
that much and it struck us as it was
time to remind people of what the agency
has really been about we were recently
chided in a review appearing in the
nation that kind of policy wonk review
by someone called Joanne K well for
launching ad hominem arguments against
the agency it's the characteristic of
policy wonks they don't like violence in
language at home in him I never thought
I'd be accusing the nation of being ad
hominem about the CIA but there it is
and the first skein of our book well the
first game is really the press and web
the second skin really is why why has
there always been from day one of the
agency's existent absolutely day one a
relationship with drug trafficking I
mean do people when they join the agency
say I really want to run drugs does it
come to them naturally or is it just
part of their function and a little the
preface really comes in the Second World
War when the predecessors of CI a
notably the Office of Naval Intelligence
and the Office of Strategic Services
it's normal huh
but commenced a relationship with
mobsters for three reasons
two had to do with the New York docks
they were worried about sabotage because
of the u-boats in the Atlantic and they
wanted the cooperation of the mob that
was one reason the second reason is they
were I think far more worried about
labor organizing by Harry bridges the
who was the leading the charge for the
longshoremen the non mob dominated
longshoremen against the ILA and the
intelligence agencies contacted my
Lansky and said they were looking for
cooperation and also they were looking
for cooperation in finding sources in
Sicily that could help them in the in
which was being planned at that time
Lucky Luciano was the what these two
called the mob kingpin if you like and
he was doing 30 years in Dannemora
prison in upstate New York in fairly
short order Lansky Lansky a con while he
contacted Luciano Luciani was moved to a
nicer prison denim or is a very rough
place indeed and was had his sentence
commuted and was deported to Italy where
in the waning years of the war and the
beginning of the peace he started
building and rebuilding his drug empire
on an international scale now if you had
a CIA man sitting right there he would
probably say they could say well you
know that was the national interest I
could make it you could make a case for
it I think the important thing probably
downplayed would be the need to crush
the left on the docks in New York
because but almost immediately
thereafter the agency its first major
task after it was founded in 47 was to
confront the possibility of legal
victories by the Italian and the French
communists at the ballot box they the
agency desperate for money the money is
another source of relationship with drug
trafficking remember that money from
drugs is you know not officially
registered money it's what you might
call black money or illegal money or
covert money unaccountable money very
importantly the agency then renewed its
ties or continued in its ties with the
with the mobs in Marseilles and in Italy
and right-wing organizations the agency
at that time at the dawn of the Cold War
was on the cutting edge of the war
against communism the war against
socialism the war against the left who
your enemy is going to be in such a war
they're going to be labor unions
organizers the communist parties of
various countries national liberation
movements who your Ally is going to be
they're going to be get para fascist
gangs they're going to be
right-wing dictators they're going to be
the propertied classes in a fairly
seamless web which you will see repeated
again and again it's the relationship
with the drug gangs is structural and
particularly when you get into what you
might call narco regimes such as for
example the Taliban such as the Salinas
brothers some of you may have seen a
story in The New York Times actually not
so long ago by Tim golden which actually
now reveals something we sort of say in
our book particularly about Raul Salinas
that that family the father of the
Salinas brothers the president former
president of Mexico and his brother the
father had been in a tie with Mexican
drug lords when they when they when the
Salinas brothers were kids
this is a long long term relationship
which evidently must have been known to
the agency wasn't endings anyway
that so therefore right from the
beginning it is not a fortuitous one
time off we had to get arms to the
Contras every time it's we had to
support Chiang kai-shek against Marty
Tung Chiang kai-shek even when he was
still in China before the war was doing
much of his business earning much of his
revenues from opium management in
mainland in what became the Chinese
People's Republic and when he was run
out by Mao his forces moved down towards
the Golden Triangle and took over the
opium trade there the CIA was supporting
Chiang kai-shek herbs was a fairly
logical development for CIA planes or of
organizations related to the CIA
beginning with Chennault Flying Tigers
originally to start flying the opium
that story led as the decades progressed
to when the CIA was trying to recruit
the tribesmen in that area to work for
them against the communists in the
National Liberation Front the Hmong
there were their relationship with drug
running continued you had CIA planes
running the the opium back into Laos and
and where it was refined into heroin and
then went into Vietnam the motive the
world the Cold War the Cold War
rationale the same thing happened at a
later date in Afghanistan in the late
80s I regime the Taraki regime this is
before the Soviets invaded the Taraki
regime in Afghanistan a reforming regime
tried to inaugurate land reforms
confiscated the opium growing estates of
the feudal lords of Afghanistan this was
immediately seen by the CIA as a threat
in the area they drew lurid scenarios of
you know the Soviets be able to rush in
and then gain their long desert warm
water port and so forth
the Soviets of course did ultimately
invade and the CIA then launched its
largest ever operation cost of over
three billion dollars in the end they
were fighting to restore the status quo
ante there are objective and actual
allies where the opium lords many much
of the fighting by the people who were
called of course those days Mujahideen
and freedom fighters there's some
confusion now and a rather rapid
transition to terrorists in a sort of
gray area while one day is terrorism and
the next day its freedom fighting in the
third day it's the unical project to run
a pipeline which of course is beyond
freedom fighting and terrorism is just
purely about money the Taliban was the
eventual consequence of all this which
has now conceded by government the guy
US government to be vying with Burma and
occasionally ahead as the leading
supplier of heroin Lee I just began with
how to support the Contras the Boland
Amendment for bad
supply military supply of the Contras in
fairly short order it began by the way
for those who feel sentimental about
Jimmy Carter with Jimmy Carter whistling
up Argentinian torturers to help form
the Contras then there was the
Congressional cutoff and in 1982 as
emerged earlier this year it was a
smoking gun actually we could have an
aside later on smoking gun theory and
complicated the whole in in journalism
when the the hunt for The Smoking Gun is
an important moment as with Nixon in
Watergate they kept saying remember
there was no smoking gun I mean usually
at that point of a thousands of smoking
gun belching smoke and they said but no
real you had Nixon you know or during
the invasion of Ellsberg's shrink you
had you know bribe money being given to
the burglars to keep quiet but they said
no real smoking gun and finally of
course the tape surfaced and that was
the smoking gun in this case they've
always said there's no smoking gun with
the CIA and drugs well the smoking gun
earlier this year surfaced actually
courtesy of the Inspector General of the
CIA
Fred hits who admitted in Congress in
1982 Casey the late William Casey
the true monster actually even by the
rather low standards of directors of the
Central Intelligence Agency there is a
sudden gradation in monster Doom I
suppose there was a left of the Nazi
Party when you think about it that's
been some sense but Casey went to
William French Smith the Attorney
General Reagan's Attorney General and
said I we want a waiver so that we do
not have to report drug-dealing
activities of our assets a waiver he was
immediately given with correspondence
was published recently by Maxine Waters
his office congressman Maxum woman
Maxine Waters a waiver was issued which
was only rescinded by the way in 1996
why 1982 the CIA at that time was
gearing up
for the arms drugs contra shuffle and
they needed the clearance which they
duly got we end that particular scan of
our narrative with Mexico where as I
just said earlier you have the u.s.
knowingly in alliance with the narco
trafficking regime as the Swiss police
inquiry which is really well this his
suddenly emerge because the Swiss police
who have built a case against Raul
Salinas and have been interviewing a lot
of mobsters and drug runners
incarcerated in various cut in countries
including this one concluded and it was
reported not so long ago Raul Salinas
was in overall charge of making sure
that drugs from the Andean countries
made their way safely through Mexico
where we extracted of course an enormous
price for that 10% of the value and
passed on to the United States this was
the the blue-eyed family much loved by
the the US business and journalistic
elites indeed carlos salinas after he
was run out of mexico was still able to
rejoice in the fact that he was a
director of The Wall Street Journal
which I believe he is to this day all
that may they may have finally flushed
him down there is another skein in our
book which is the nature of drug wars
well one of the prime commonly believed
to be a tremendous fight to prevent the
trafficking and consumption of drugs
which is a idea should I think disabuse
yourself immediately drug was a private
to ensure that people the drugs are
trafficked you fight a war to make sure
the drugs have moved in the direction
you want them the classic example is
though are the two wars fought by
Britain against China known correctly as
the opium wars in the 19th century when
the Chinese Empire and its declining
decades did not want opium from India to
be imported
into China by the British the British
thought it was a splendid idea of which
they'd make lots of money so they said
we will and they fought two wars and
prevailed and delivered a very very
large amount of opium into China and
we're only finally forced in 1920 by
international opinion to stop doing it
many of the what are now the most
respected names in British business life
like jardin and maths and began their
lives as opium traders out of Hong Kong
so wars are fought to ensure but drugs
are moved you could actually argue in
some ways the Afghan war was like that
because the Afghan war restored the
ability of the feudal lords to move
their opium the Taraki regime had tried
to eradicate open grain just as the most
addict regime in Iran in 90 in the early
1950s overthrown a CIA coup was also
trying to wipe out the drug run these
are wars fought to make sure and you
could argue that many was in Latin
America had the same intent if you want
land reform the enemy of any CIA
director and any US government which
might lessen heighten the power of
peasants you attack peasant organizing
and you hand the regime over or ensure
its run by thugs and gangsters who of
course are the narco traffickers a
second purpose of drug wars is of course
social control and I read argue
certainly in this country the prime
motive now and again we trace that
history back into the 19th century when
for example in the 1870s when they were
abundant Chinese laborers in this
country particularly in the West
building roads and rail railroads in the
1870s when there was pressure because of
economic recession against them as
they're thought to be taking jobs away
there was immediately a ferocious attack
on them for opium consumption they
smoked opium simultaneous in the middle
classes were taking a lot of opium but
they were taking it in liquid form as
tonics I mean I can remember growing up
in Ireland tonics survived quite quite
robustly as a matter of fact my
grandmother was always taking something
called doctor colas brands patent
medicines transfers
transparent liquid which is essentially
liquid opium she took with great
gratification that was one of the early
examples of social control and you can
follow that thread through the 20th
century will fought with increasing
ferocity one of the demonic figures here
is Harry Anslinger head of the Bureau of
Narcotics and dangerous drugs who was
absolute ERISA was a violent racist this
is a malign and awful of figures as
Jerry Hoover actually of the FBI but not
nearly so well known in our newsletter
counterpunch we just ran an interesting
piece about Anslinger by a guy called
Doug Valentine who did the best book on
the CIA's Phoenix program in Vietnam its
campaign of assassinations and zinger
was always intent on heightening the the
so to speak racist rhetorical impact of
drug war fighting he renamed hemp
marihuana to try and associate popular
tried to popularize the name rather
successfully to associate it with with
Hispanics and Mexicans he launched
savage raids and arrests on black jazz
musicians in particular and sportsmen
and in association with congressman Hale
Boggs for those of you who like to think
of these lineages the father of Cokie
Roberts
and of the chief Democratic lobbyist on
the hill
Tommy Boggs Hale Boggs who disappeared
over Alaska actually never to reappear
put through in the 50s the first
mandatory sentencing for drugs when the
first death penalty
for the death penalty was all sponsored
by Anslinger the drug war was most
piffle ii expressed i could just read up
the quit [ __ ] for thee by richard
nixon actually when speaking privately
nixon always had a very helpful
frankness about him i found he really
some presidents even in private had the
need to wrap it up but i'll dick just
didn't he said it like it is and it's
worth finding the quote hold him on page
73 as he was pondering the initiation of
his drug roll with Haldeman Haldeman
noted in his diary in 1969 after talking
with Nixon quote Nixon emphasized that
you have to face the fact that the whole
problem is really the blacks the key is
to devise a system that recognizes this
while not appearing to very helpful
little quotation while not appearing to
and really from there you know it's a
pretty straight line with the drug water
what we now have which is astronomic a
prison population with an incredible
imbalance of black and hispanic people
largely courtesy of of course the crack
and powder cocaine imbalance in
sentencing of 100 to one which really
cracked off was for those who like to
feel as a bipartisan government at work
really pushed through by Tip O'Neill in
the mid 80s Tip O'Neill oddly enough a
big proponent of the Boland amendment on
the one hand but O'Neill came from
Boston and there was a huge huge uproar
when Len Bias died and it was attributed
to crack O'Neill thought they could get
ahead of the president at that time
ahead of Reagan by putting in savage
laws they vied with each other the white
house the Reagan White House and the
Democrat
on the hill - which could do the most
savage laws and sentencing structures
and the result is more or less what we
have now there were efforts by the US
Sentencing Commission not so long ago to
say this imbalance between hardik and
crack cocaine the 1/10 much more used by
middle class the crack cocaine of course
used by the poor there's no scent
there's no rationale for it
sentencing should be the same this call
by the US Sentencing Commission was
rejected by Reno's Justice Department by
the Congress and by Bill Clinton in a
ratification of a drug war as racist and
selectively racist of course as the
original first war against the Chinese I
actually the drug war now is so deeply
embedded there every now and again
there's a call to when the drug Ward's
it's now so so embedded into the
economies of law enforcement that it's
it's hard to imagine it being a I come
from Humboldt County in Northern
California when I left we are
approaching the peak of our production
of not me but many of my neighbors of
marijuana and of course the campaign
against marijuana production camp is
also in full tilt in fact the day I left
I saw three helicopters from the local
cops and their new wrinkle this ways the
cops now hang from a rope underneath
with their foot through a look moving a
hundred feet above the ground looking
down to see see the plants but you know
they're budgeting depends on the dope
they find and then with that budget will
come more money into a fairly depressed
area of California which means more
building and means more cars for the
cops and so forth multiply this in every
jurisdiction and you get and then put on
top of that the enormous lobbies now in
every state for the the prison lobby
prison building Lobby the water's lobby
you know these are vast lobbies now in a
way consequent of
the drug walk so the drug was gonna be a
very hard thing to stop that is the
second thing the third theme really is a
theme which kind of is the core thought
I think of the book the essential
continuity in some ways between the
Nazis and Nazi methods and methods of
state repression picked up in the Cold
War we say right up front in our book
that very often people talk about a
rogue agent or a rogue agency the CIA
it's sort of comforting in a way because
it implies of course that the ship of
state is moving in a dignified and legal
fashion while the sort of pirate ship
the CIA is swerving about doing all the
dirty work it's not the proper way of
thinking of it I don't think we say
essentially the the CIA is carrying out
as a bureaucratic organization the the
commands of government right from the
word go of course if you go back and
read the original founding document of
the CIA written by Clark Clifford
there's a slight gray area and always
had to be a gray area you could not have
him it requisitioned on paper from JFK
please kill Fidel Castro tomorrow
morning but as you follow this through
there is a bun that's been of course a
lot of work in particular about the
league the campaign of the Kennedy
brothers to have Castro assassinated
that the fingerprints are slightly more
clear than usual it's a bit more
difficult for example to track it down
with the with the murder of the young
brothers in South Vietnam or Lumumba but
the CIA is not running a thwart US
government policy it's part of
government and it's much it's helpful to
remember that or not delude oneself with
talk about a rogue agency the essential
continuity might sound a rough way of
putting it but we we spent some time in
this book looking at the efforts of the
US intelligence agencies initially Army
Intelligence
so assessing the others and then the CAA
to to bring out the Nazi scientists and
take full use of their experiments in
their researches as carried out in
concentration camps some of the vilest
there's some very good work again been
done on this particularly by Chris
Simpson
some of you may have read his books the
vibe the vilest doctors the most
appalling criminals were brought her
protected relocated and their researches
carried forward again of course in the
name of national security but we're
talking not just about of course now LSD
which was that came a little bit later
in the 50s but they were looking very
closely at all the experiments in mind
control which the Nazis were very
interested in in the various
concentration camps and the CIA's
Technical Services Division headed by a
man called Gottlieb Sidney Gottlieb whom
we have a whole chapter about took full
measure and full account of this Nazi
work as did all the researchers into
chemical and biological warfare this
particular skein I think is well resumed
in the figure of Klaus Barbie Barbie the
butcher of Lyon was much sought by the
French at the end of the war US
intelligence military intelligence
actually found him or what he found them
after unpleasant experience at the hands
of the British intelligence
organisations and they debriefed him
protected him and eventually had him
shipped to Bolivia under a new identity
this is all now been thoroughly
documented where he became and here you
have a lot of the threads of the book
joined together he became a CIA asset
one a security adviser a expert in
torture techniques and security antics
for the various butchers and thugs
running the bolivian government for
example he was associated with the hunt
of the captured Che Guevara and finally
he of course was in close cahoots with
the with the big drug smuggling
gangs Bobby is a very symbolic figure
these are the themes of the book now
what are we not saying we're not saying
that if there haven't been a CIA there
would be no drugs in America clearly
which shake the Nation magazine accused
us is saying if the lunatic thing to say
that the drug market and it's not caused
by the CIA although some some people
actually like a Lavigne former DEA man
they argue with something which we don't
in our books that the you know at some
points CIA supervise cocaine from Latin
America was a very very large part of
the import I don't know we don't say
that in our book we're more interested
in showing really the agenda of the
state if the agenda of the state is the
preservation support of right-wing thug
regimes abroad and the maintenance of
social control at home which means
control supervision and if necessary
imprisonment of the dangerous classes
that if that is the agenda of the state
then we can follow through how that
agenda was carried forward that's the
way it happens if it wasn't the agenda
of the state that still be drugs but the
atmosphere might be different there
might be different emphases not the
insane emphasis on punishment maybe more
emphasis on counseling someone said to
me are you saying the secret
organization supervising drug
trafficking in this country run by the
government I said yes absolutely it's
called the Federal Reserve why you could
argue taking a longer look that the
Federal Reserve sets in large measure
economic not totally but have
responsible in large part for economic
policy and from economic policy flow the
riches and prosperity for some poverty
and misery for others but with poverty
and misery comes a rise in drug
consumption comes an increase in the
need for in some form of employment by
desperate in a city black youth with
maybe the only career opportunity at
that point being crack running or
whatever so you could if you want to you
can blame the Federal Reserve
but the agenda of the state is what
cants and that brings us full circle
back to the press is the press just like
the CIA never rogue not entirely it's a
more subtle relationship I think we've
seen between web and now just how tight
the reins are this is not to say there
aren't many courageous journalists who
have done wonderful work in exposing the
narco-trafficking realities in the last
10 years last 20 years whether it be al
McCoy or actually I should invoke my own
brother Andrew and my sister-in-law
Leslie Coburn who did some spectacular
documentaries in the middle 80s and
there are others Bob Perry and Brian
Barger working for AP in the middle 80s
did spectacular work there are people
honest US government employees the DEA
's cellar costea
and others who tried to protest and try
to bring the reality but the press the
mainstream press has exceptions but the
tendency will be to protect and conceal
that's the tendency you can't make an
absolute rule someone's excuse me of
insufficiently theorizing the role of
the press and the relationship between
the press and the CIA and the CIA well
it's hard to theorize but you can get
the drift of it with a couple of quotes
which maybe I'll give you if you'll bear
with me Katherine Graham now Katherine
Graham as you know the heroine of
Watergate the the chairman of the
Washington Post company now in 1988
Graham told CIA recruits quote we live
in a dirty and dangerous world there are
some things the general public does not
need to know and shouldn't I believe
democracy flourishes when the government
can take legitimate steps to keep its
secrets and when the press can decide
whether to print what it knows well as a
robust statement
it lacks it lacks sort of muscle but the
implication is very clear when the press
or the people running the
press'll only in the press think the
state agenda requires it keep your mouth
shut the other is from a guy called
Keith Schneider who was working at the
New York Times at the time of the Carey
report which the press almost totally
ignored carry report you might think
rather than it wasn't just Gary Webb
this was of the San Jose Mercury News
this was a full press investigation by a
senator and a large committee came to
after prolonged inquiry came to
conclusions not so far from Webb's and
almost totally ignored then Schneider
had done for the New York Times a
three-part series dismissing allegations
of contra drug traffic and then in these
Times Magazine asked him why he'd done
that and he said that such a story
ie to ratify that the agency had been in
bed with the traffickers could quote
shatter the Republic I think it is so
damaging the implications are so
extraordinary that for us to run the
story it had better be based on the most
solid evidence we could amass which
really means you'd have to have a signed
statement from the Director of Central
Intelligence saying we did it we get it
and we're proud of it so there people
often say a reading I know I always hate
to read my books because I know people
might fall asleep but I will read the
last paragraph as the CIA turned 50 in
1997 it attempted to define its role in
a world no longer containing the Soviet
Union what it came up with was a plan to
combat something it had done so much to
encourage over the fast first
half-century of its existence
international crime among the CIA's
proposed targets for preserving its
slice of the 27 billion intelligence
budget were money laundering illegal
immigration drug smuggling and chemical
and biological terrorism only three
years earlier the CIA was still enjoying
an exemption from reporting the drug
activities of any of its associates if
they were alive to read the
cia's prospectus for the third
millennium the ghosts of Lucky Luciano
may olanski Chiang kai-shek George
hunter white Barry seal and thousands of
others would surely have laughed at the
effrontery of their old partner in crime
so I'll stop there and maybe we can have
questions thank you